Britta Sharma is building up one of the
world's richest historical legacies he's
spent years going all over the world
interviewing World War two veterans with
each passing week and month there are of
course fewer survivors to speak to but
he's already captured the memories of
more than a thousand veterans an
invaluable bank of memories for the
future we are privileged that the young
man is joining us now hello to you rich
it's good to talk to you appreciate you
taking the time
you're just 22 but you are clearly
passionate about what you're doing why
do you love it so much well I appreciate
you taking the time to talk about the
heroes of the Second World War with me
ever since I was a little kid I've
always been interested in the Second
World War and when I was in high school
I just wanted to meet these men face to
face because frankly if it wasn't for
men who fought for the Allied side
during the worst war in humanity people
like me would not exist and you know I'm
grateful to be alive
and I'm very conscious of the fact that
many 19 18 20 year-olds were killed so
that you know someone like me could have
a chance out of life and I find it to be
my responsibility to document the
reality of the combat that these men
from all the different Allied countries
went through so that we could live in a
world where you know every day our homes
are not bombed out or where we have the
freedom to go up to anyone and say
whatever we want without fear of
repercussions you know those things were
bought with bloodshed and sacrifice if
people as real as you and I and and we
owe it to the men who were killed that
it's not going to happen again do you
feel that that you want to speak to
soldiers who fought as the enemy at the
time as well no so the the nonprofit I
run heroes of the Second World War our
main focus is to interview Allied combat
veterans I mean while I appreciate the
importance from
historical standpoint to gathering both
sides of any story I personally wouldn't
be comfortable because these men are my
they're my best friends they're my
heroes and I don't think anyone would
ever want to associate with someone that
was trying to hurt or even killed their
friends also I wouldn't want to add to
the injustice of the Holocaust or The
Rape of Nanking I mean that six-year-old
that that six-year-old girl that was
shoved in a gas chamber I mean whether
we like it or not she's completely
forgot into history and and you know I
would find it difficult that I would be
providing a lasting legacy for the
families of some of the German or
Japanese veterans whereas that little
girl family is never gonna have anything
of her you know and that's what's so
powerful about these interviews that I
do with the veterans is that you know
200 years from now their great great
great grandkids will still get to be
able you know to hear them and listen to
them and look at the way you know they
spoke and the way they acted and you
know it makes them so much more real and
in a sense it's giving them an extended
life and and I find the people who are
most deserving of that are the people
who saved the world and gave them and
gave us all these opportunities not the
ones who tried to take it away she I
know and I'm sure that many people
listening this morning will know from
personal experience speaking to parents
grandparents whatever that it's
difficult to get them to open up about
what happened to some of them during the
war memories that they want to lock away
have you found that a challenge at times
you're absolutely right so I've been
honored that I've been able to meet you
sober thousand Second World War combat
veterans and what I've noticed is you
know my age is actually such a big asset
you could say I'm the same age many of
these men were when they were in combat
I do loads of research before each
interview but most importantly I don't
I'm not related to any of these heroes
so there's no emotional attachment
that's the thing that stops a lot of the
men from
sharing with their families is that they
love them so much that they wouldn't
even want them to have to think about
what they had to go through in the war
but when I come along a total stranger
it gives these heroes an opportunity to
get all of this stuff off of their
chests and it could be very cathartic it
ends up often being a therapy session
because no one who saw their best
friend's getting to older who has to
kill someone just to survive another day
should have that locked away in their
head you know for a day let alone 75
years and so it's important that these
men know that it's okay what they had to
do and what they had to witness and that
we're grateful for it and oftentimes
when I send the DVDs of the interview to
the family I mean they'll talk about
they'll reach out and say they've heard
you know hours of things that they
didn't even know about or that their
father didn't want to share with them
and and eventually that will lead to a
conversation and they'll have that
understanding which is you know so
important but any of the family members
who feel that their dad or their
grandfather does not talk to them please
don't take that as a sign of disrespect
but rather a sign of love they just
don't want you to even have to harbour
the thoughts of what the war was like
okay mushy great work that you're doing
we appreciate you taking the time to
join us and also to stay up so late to
speak to us no worries the only thing I
wanted to say is them I'm still
interviewing Second World War combat
veterans so if anyone knows any please
do reach out it's at heroes of the
Second World War org we interview the
veterans we put it on DVDs we mail it to
them it's all for free and please do
reach out okay heroes of the Second
World War
dot org again thanks for joining us
Russia we do very much appreciate it
thanks a lot you too you too get some
sleep thank you